[Music]  anyone check out the Nickelodeon Kids  Choice Awards they had the other day did  you see those Andy I have not seen them  yet  okay sure that I've you know I watched  it I have kids and I also watch the  Nickelodeon Kids Choice Awards I have to  say I found the lineup of stars to be  just a little odd 2012 Kids Choice  Awards hosted by Will Smith with  appearances by former Secretary of Labor  German Chancellor Angela Merkel Amazon  CEO Jeff Bezos political activist Cornel  West the West Memphis Three  crazy naked Coney guy  part of it I had a good time I have to  say yeah you should have been built  higher than the crazy naked Kony guy the  I have a bad agent  sorry bring it up